thank you Yasser we are with Stephen
burgard the president of Cardinal
Glennon Children's Hospital tell us
about uh what you do there and your
connection with the St Louis chess club
sure so I'm six years now in St Louis as
president of Cardinal Glennon and uh
Colonel Glennon is one of the country's
top 50 Children's Hospitals full service
and we represent uh the care and needs
of children everything from routine
doctors visits with a primary care
pediatrician all the way to heart
transplants and neonatal ICU trauma
services and everything that the
children throughout our region might
need with a special emphasis in heart
for the most vulnerable and what is the
connection with the Saint Louis chess
club talk to us about that so
um so one of my children was very
interested in in chess and a very close
friend of mine was involved with the
annual chess event and so I actually
joined up in support of his work and
enjoyed the event and had the passion
that everyone had for helping children
realize their full potential in every
way in this case through chess that I
chose to involved about three years ago
you are also the chairman for this
year's strategy across the board Gala
that we used the race funds tell us a
bit about that sure so for this classic
chess programs uh you know funds are
needed in order to to create the support
for the program staff and and the work
with the kids and Colonel Glennon out of
the 600 000 kids that are in our region
we serve over a hundred thousand of
those kids every single year in primary
care and about a hundred thousand kids
in you know the hospital and other
places so the idea was that we have an
opportunity also to help children become
more engaged in chess and the event
represents such a great way to connect
with the community and give back that my
wife and I felt very passionate about
this work absolutely and we see some
graphics about strategy across the board
how can people join how can the public
join so uh go to St Louis
chessclub.org so all the information is
there it's at the chase and it's in the
course on Ballroom it's gorgeous a very
famous room here in St Louis and there's
also a chance to participate in our
silent auctions for those who aren't in
St Louis you can participate as well and
support the kids and donate and help
expand programs Stephen do you play
chess do you play with your son I only
play with my son and he wins who's
winning okay that was my next question
it's just been a great experience and a
joy for me and in fact at the hospital
now we have a program with the chess
club more than 60 children just in the
very first year have been engaged with
someone to Mentor them in chess and it
has created great relationships with
their parents so if you're hospitalized
for seven days ten days and you're a
child and you don't get to move around
so much what do you do in your free time
learning and playing chess with your
family is a great gift and something
we're proud to share with these children
that's amazing thank you for everything
you do guys any questions yeah Stephen
first of all once again our welcome
welcome welcome good to see you on the
show thank you for everything you did
you do I remember as a 13 year old I
went to the Children's Orthopedic
Hospital in Seattle and I once did a
chess simultaneous against uh the
children in the ward that I visited and
it was a really endearing experience do
you have programs like that where chess
Grandmasters can go to the hospital and
and play with the kids yes so that was
the heart of our share of the
partnership was to invest in bringing
Grand Masters and excellent chess
players like yourself into relationship
with our children again since they're
there for a week to 10 days on average
it's just a great opportunity for them
not only to experience the Journey of
their health concerns but also
participate in learning new things so
whether that's music dance art other
creative therapies but certainly chess
has been an extraordinarily positive and
popular program for us we have an events
coordinator that works with individuals
to get them to participate with the kids
and schedules everything so it's just
been a phenomenal to give these kids
that type of experience and I'm sure one
of them will be winning one of these
very soon nice for sure for sure it's a
great program thank you for that Stephen
very very nice and good luck with your
strategies across the board and again
folks can
um it's called a silent auction you'll
see all kinds of items and things that
the people
can bid on and everything that's raised
goes to the program there so again
Stephen thank you for your leadership
great